the American right has been very
successful at putting American Social
Democrats in this corner by accusing
them of wanting ridiculously high tax
rates and they've actually been
successful at doing this with a lot of
different issues so for example with
abortion the right says abortions murder
we're against it the left wants abortion
no matter what obviously that's not true
the left wants safe legal abortion up to
a certain point depending on the health
of the mother there's a bunch of
different nuance in there the right is
for lower taxes lower them as much as
possible because hey it's my money for
the most part the left is about nuanced
dialed-in tax policies that make sense
and are defended by research not just
take everybody's money
so when congresswoman alexandria Acacio
courts has proposed the 70% marginal tax
rate we looked at it very carefully and
first of all we explained marginal tax
rates we explained it's not 70 percent
of everyone's money it's 70 percent on
income above a certain level it might be
above 5 million in earnings others have
floated 10 million in earnings then we
looked at is there historical precedent
for such a level of Taxation and the
answer is yes there is even the you know
in the United States then we looked at
what does the research say about top
marginal tax rates and we found that
there's actually lots of research which
says that the rate that maximizes
government revenue is a top marginal tax
rate of somewhere seventy seventy three
percent according to an MIT study and
that assumes that you start that top
rate at a certain level of income maybe
five million maybe ten million who knows
okay in comes new congresswoman alon
omar who was interviewed recently who is
going a step further she wants a snot a
70% top tax rate but she is floating the
idea of a 90 percent top tax rate to
start with for the 1% now what doesn't
make sense about that a 90 percent
marginal rate for the 1% think about
that for a second we'll watch her
explain it and then we'll dig into it
take a look
a little few things that we can do one
of them is that we could increase the
taxes that people are paying who are the
extremely wealthy in our communities so
70% 80% we've had it as high as 90% the
other thing that we can do is we can tax
corporations or or have them level out
the gap that that exists is with their
workers I'm also one that really looks
at the defense budget that we have that
has increased in nearly 50% since 9/11
and so most of the money that we have in
there it's much more than we spend on
education on health care I mean I think
what picks up for a lot of people is
taxing the rich up to 80 90 percent or
70 degree and you know 1% was paying a
fair share yeah so the thing there is
the 1% must pay tax rates up to 90
percent I believe that this is simply
bad policy informed by or maybe better
said uninformed by a real knowledge of
the facts and I'll tell you exactly what
I'm talking about in 2018 to be in the
top 1% of the United States you needed
to earn 421 thousand dollars okay 421
thousand dollars puts you in the top 1%
so the suggestion here implicitly is
that she would at least consider a
policy where once you get to the top 1%
or earnings of 421 thousand dollars you
start to pay as much as 90 percent tax
on income above that now remember many
states have income taxes like for
example Massachusetts of 5.3 percent so
under that idea if you live in
Massachusetts and make over 400 21,000
you pay ninety five point three percent
marginal tax rate on all of your income
above that threshold now I know the
defense's people are going to send to me
David she was spitballing 70 80 or 90
percent she didn't mean just the 1%
maybe the tax brackets are different I
believe that this is a missed
both in spirit and by the letter and I'm
willing to be led here by the
peer-reviewed research on this issue I
have not seen evidence that starting a
90 percent marginal tax bracket at 421
thousand dollars is what we need to be
doing now there will be people who say
David hold on there's precedent during
the Eisenhower era ninety-one percent
marginal tax rate well yes yes and no in
the 19 in 1950 it's true that there was
a ninety-one percent marginal tax rate
on incomes over two hundred thousand
dollars number one that's equivalent to
two million today not the 1% right not
four hundred and twenty one thousand two
million inflation adjusted that's just a
fraction of the top one percent you're
not in the 1% today if you earn two
million you're way way way above that
but the more important thing is that
that ninety-one percent marginal tax
rate during the Eisenhower era was
combined with a bunch of other rules
that exempted a lot of income from the
ninety-one percent rate so the effective
tax rates for a lot of people were
actually lower than they are today
even in high tax brackets because a lot
of those exemptions so my challenge to
Alanna Mar is explained to me the data
behind a 90 percent marginal tax rate on
incomes in the 1 percent meaning
starting at 421 thousand dollars what I
would support once again is what I've
seen backed by research and data which
is we need higher tax brackets right now
the highest bracket and starts at I
think it's five hundred and ten thousand
dollars or five hundred and twenty
thousand dollars we need higher brackets
I don't know if there needs to be a
bracket at a million and five and ten
million or what it needs to be we need
higher brackets I've seen no data that
ninety percent is the right number for
that top marginal tax rate I've seen no
data that we should be trying to collect
that rate from people in the four
hundred thousand dollar income range so
what I would support is a system that's
progressive with a high marginal rate
around 70 percent for the top of that
one percent and scaling up from the I
believe it's 37 percent top rate now up
to that seventy percent the
problem with this idea is that it allows
the right to caricature the left 70
percent marginal on five million totally
defensible academically totally
defensible economically totally
defensible historically ninety percent
tax rate starting on incomes at four
hundred and twenty one thousand dollars
that is not to the based on all of the
research I've been doing on this issue
for years the policy that we should be
pursuing and I also think it's a
strategic mistake because now the right
is going to seize on this and they'll go
to Alexandria Cassio Cortes and they'll
say do you disagree with your colleague
who's talking about ninety percent tax
on the one percent or is the problem
actually the super-rich and should we be
doing seventy percent and now AOC will
have to say no my colleague was right in
spirit but we might have different just
know this is not ideological we actually
have an opportunity here with the new
progressive movement in the Democratic
Party in the house to get united on some
of these key issues in equality being
one of them and having Alana Marseille
maybe ninety percent because the one
percent need to pay it's a mistake it's
not backed by data that I've seen and
it's only going to muddy the waters
let's be clear on what the policy should
be and I don't believe that this is the
policy that we should actually be
pursuing on the left if you disagree
with me let me know I am of course on
Instagram at David Pakman the show is on
Instagram at David Pakman show followed
both of us there one of today's sponsors
is privacy calm slash Pakman this is a
free service that I've actually been
using myself for a while now and I love
it you just take a few seconds to link
your debit card or bank account to
privacy calms mobile app or browser
extension for Firefox and Chrome and
what that does is allow you to instantly
create virtual credit cards that are
linked to your bank account so that
you're not actually putting your real
debit card number on the Internet and
you use these virtual credit card
numbers to buy things on
and with one click of a button you have
the ability to create multiple virtual
cards delete cards freeze and unfreeze
cards you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5 towards your first purchase when
you sign up using that link below